Nikki Hilton reacts to Kim Kardashian
paying her sister Paris the ultimate
compliment
I really would want to do anything for
her she literally gave me a career and I
like totally acknowledge that but Paris
isn't the only family member making
headlines Nicky's aunt Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills star Kyle Richards is
set to reprise her role in the upcoming
Halloween movie your close I just heard
that I'm actually gonna see Kyle this
weekend I'm going to her fashion show I
don't like scary movies at all but I
know I'm excited to see the reboot et
spoke with the heiress at Vanity Fair's
best-dressed lists party in New York
City where she revealed when she feels
like her most fashionable self when I'm
wearing something unique so usually when
I'm wearing young upcoming designer
something from overseas
because your party you never want to
blend in such boring
I love fashion I love dressing up and
coming to an event like this you know
everyone is going to be decked but being
beautiful and it's fun to see what
everyone's wearing yeah
[Applause]
[Music]